I went to Vegas by the way did you watch
Oscars no what happened no neither
I went to Vegas
did something happen this weekend no I
don't know I don't see anything just
seemed like a regular old award show to
me yeah should we talk about it
what
this right here
how many views does this have like three
70 million views they really want us to
watch this show look talk about a viral
moment you know on one hand wow on one
hand
is Chris's cheek and on the other hand
I will admit some of the memes got me
chocolate some dude this was the
funniest [ __ ] thing I've seen in ever
that's the funniest part first of all
everyone trying to make this about
themselves just [ __ ] you like it's just
it's too funny you can't make it about
you get over it what do you mean make it
about you that when that [ __ ] happened
the how fast people went to Twitter and
started lecturing about assault and like
all kinds of other stuff I'm not saying
it's right on any other day these these
people are not having
you know aren't making these points and
it's like I think when will hit Chris so
many celebrities saw that and were like
I didn't know you could do that
supremely jealous but like I think the
reason why people were tweeting right
away is like the uneasiness the feeling
of him just walking back and sitting
down in the same place and the show just
like carrying on I was like what how is
that even yeah no it's great not being
dragged out of this place right now
that's what made it funny it's not right
but it made it [ __ ] hilarious right
and there's no good take here's the
other thing when people are getting on
Twitter being like that was assault like
every Popeye's employee rolled their
eyes at that they're like shut the [ __ ]
up it's not right but you can get hit at
work right it happens you know Waffle
House employees Popeyes employees they
know it yeah but those people get
dragged out but I'm just saying no one
anticipates being swung on on a waffle
order but it happens right okay you know
drunk guy walks in he's like where's my
biscuit you know they start saying crazy
stuff the Popeye's cashiers like I do
not make enough for this then the drunk
guy is like well you make enough for
these hands and then now you're getting
hit with like a [ __ ] you know uh a
deep fry basket and all kinds of [ __ ] so
I'm not saying it's right but you can
definitely get hit at work hmm so this
like rich person idea that like oh
that's assault you can't do that well in
the real world people do that [ __ ]
laughs
again it's not right how about that take
what I'm here like let's really defend
violence I mean that's why I say it's
not right but it happens it happens but
also there's like there's like security
here this is supposed to be a pretty
buttoned up event is it not I mean yeah
like there doesn't need to be a reality
check no I'm not saying the reality
check is that nobody [ __ ] watches the
Oscars anymore well now we do yeah now
we now we are yeah I feel like that's
what I'm saying they like we got played
it should have been [ __ ] boring I'm
pissed that this happened I'm pissed
that this happened because now people
are gonna like [ __ ] we're in this
weird place where people worship
celebrities but it seems to be going
down because nobody really cares about
the Oscars anymore and whatever but then
something like this happens and it's the
biggest [ __ ] event in the last 10
years I mean hey a fry cook had Smack
The Waffle House that gets a lot of
views too you know they're just they're
just working with the formula yeah
that's true yeah I know all this [ __ ] I
just said is gonna have people's [ __ ]
blood boiling dude no
I just think well but as a comedian
though are you prepped to get hit hey if
I say some wild ass [ __ ] and someone
comes up on stage and punches you I just
know it can happen that has existed
before this people being crazy you know
I might say a joke at a club and I'm
just hoping security is going to do what
they're supposed to do
I say something that someone doesn't
like it it can happen yeah I'm not
saying it's right but it can he was
clearly pretty [ __ ] pissed right yeah
he probably shouldn't have hit him I
don't think that's like the stand-up
move in that in that scenario sure the
fact that he just like went back and sat
down and then like like do you think the
producers are just like what do we do no
The Producers were like he's supposed to
be the guy that wins it all I think the
producers were stoked they were like
let's keep him here oh yeah yeah yeah
they're like let it let it marinate just
to get people talking yeah security was
like oh we got it they're like no we
don't know because guess what he's gonna
win yeah they loved that yeah in fact
we're not only not gonna drag him out of
here yeah we're gonna give him the
highest honor of the night
I want to [ __ ] people up I want to be
very clear
um I'm speaking with satire here I
really don't have a strong opinion one
way or the other I just think is one of
the funniest things to ever happen I I
literally mean ever okay the [ __ ]
Fresh Prince of Bel Air got up on a
stage and smacked the [ __ ] out of the
guy from my first comedy special DVD I I
was like
he smacked them too smacked the
beautiful form like just like like that
that's our toes and everything
[Music]
that's why you could say whatever about
assault and as a comedian this and that
I don't care because it doesn't change
you can be right but it doesn't change
that this is one of the funniest things
ever bro the sound Chris Rock made that
[ __ ] was crazy oh
and the subsequent reaction wow
he has to stand there on TV and go Will
Smith just smacked the [ __ ] out of me
what a [ __ ] sentence dude yeah and
then he goes
like something like that he just says
something like nothing he does like can
you play it are we gonna get copyrighted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Will Smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
map
wow dude
a little Peter in the background she won
she won the whole thing yeah yeah she
won the whole she had the best seat she
really but I'm just saying that she made
this clip so much better oh yeah her
being like just finally realizing oh
this isn't fake yeah she's like oh that
that whoa she lets out of that wow she's
like oh wow
oh my
God keep going
yeah it was a GI Jane joke he [ __ ]
oh that's hot
okay that right there [ __ ] okay I
think he said max for stabbing
oh stacks for mapping I think out of all
the memes and all the tweets I saw I
don't know why but I thought Ben's was
the funniest honestly oh what did he say
I think he said
your wife on my [ __ ] mouth
I don't know why I thought that was so
funny I'm just saying everyone gave your
wife out of my [ __ ] mouth why can't I
stop kissing your wife like when will
did that every podcaster every comedian
should have just looked to the sky and
said thank you will he he made their
career last two days long yeah okay all
these people arguing about right and
wrong they owe it to will to give them
something to argue about yeah you know
what I mean he created something again
I'm not saying it's right but it is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah I can't believe
this is a real clip oh I mean like and
like the layers of of uh of background
like when you dig into it more right
like the whole Jada thing where she's
like in an open relationship and that
whole thing just adds layers to this
where you're like and jokes and just
like I saw some meme that was like
Jada's reaction if Chris had made the
joke about will instead and she's just
sitting there laughing oh yeah dude
that's like dude I liked a couple tweets
that had me rolling like this one this
is so simple but goddamn gonna kill me
that's why he got sent to Bel Air in the
first place [ __ ] like that
what did Jesus say from decent yeah
diesel said something y'all reporting
Will Smith on the citizen app
Chris Rock's uh reaction after getting
hit in its best face and then it's like
Will Smith's reaction after hitting
Chris Rock and it's him crying giving a
speech
can I say I like that it happened yeah
yeah can I say that yeah you know Elena
and I were just talking about something
random
can Alex my production system message me
he goes
do Will Smith just smack the [ __ ] out of
Chris Rock I'm like huh he sends me the
clip and then I'm just watching it oh my
[ __ ] laptop like
and then I'm just like
let's go yeah dude when like the when
the first reply was this has to be fake
I'm like oh yes dude I think you know
this the thing that made it feel fake
was the way Chris like leaned his head
out to the left and he's like oh and
he's like leaning to the left almost in
anticipation no I mean he obviously sees
the swing coming so he like cowers a
little bit no no I mean this like the
fact that his head is kind of sticking
out to the side yeah and then after he
gets hit I think he's like what are you
gonna do kind of like that like yeah
let's get this in slow motion
[Music]
like he does not expect that Adam no no
no no no no I'm not saying it's fake at
all I feel like the thing that really
lets you know that it's is real is that
let it let it run when Chris he does
like this little look did you just
[ __ ] hit me yeah that walk off
that walk-off is crazy yeah it really is
it's like all right my work here is done
dude I'm laughing because I really
looked at you and said hey man you know
Waffle House employees get hit and you
went that's not the right take man
it was funny I'm pissed that it happened
but I'm happy I just wish it was
something like not the Oscars yeah
because yeah you want yeah we it felt
like it was finally gonna go away I know
no but now next year that's gonna be
[ __ ] bro if they just start
incorporating you know next year they're
like all right how can we send yeah they
start doing cold opens like yeah yeah
they're like how can we send what do you
mean called opens
what everything that happens here is 100
real yeah
you can imagine next year's like how can
we send Chrissy Teigen through a table
[Laughter]
how can we get the rock to send Chrissy
Teigen through a table safely safely
Chrissy Tegan yeah she's not even an
actor yeah it doesn't matter she's
famous yeah but that would just get
Twitter going Owen how can we get Edward
Cullen to spit in someone's mouth you
think you're gonna watch next year
no lightning can't strike twice you know
it's not gonna happen unless they
advertise it yeah the Oscars promotions
just get take a hard left but why would
you even watch the Oscars tap in this
here like why you have no idea what can
go down
March 29th gave my wives
name at your [ __ ]
Oscars 2023 Betty White
isn't actually dead
she can't swears on stage the rock just
she comes back into Bane mask and a
[ __ ] like exo suit
you thought it was over for me
I'm here for my Awards yeah I would
[ __ ] watch it if it was like that
yeah see if it was a movie I would watch
it yeah okay you know yeah it's not it's
just about movies I don't give a [ __ ]
about who's gonna win the statue [ __ ]
you
and all I'm saying is
you might get hit at your job
it can happen it's not right but it can
happen yeah but I mean like when you're
going to your job you should know that
you're not going to get pointed no you
should definitely expect to not get
punched but it can happen it can happen
you know it's like you're a shitty
manager but like then you would expect
some consequences right yeah for sure
yeah yeah all that yeah that you know
Society rules yeah all that sure you
could you could be a manager that cracks
too many jokes a dude's wife is it's
it's open in the office everyone knows
this wife his wife gets
what
piped out Sexton by other people you
know and the whole office is cracking
jokes and you might crack one in front
of the crowd and then it's just bad
timing yeah right buddy slept six hours
instead of seven and
it's lights out for you yeah okay it's
not right yeah there's probably
consequences but it happens it could
happen punching happens yeah punching
happens punching happens that's just a
slap happens yes slaps happen
that's the lesson yeah
slaps happen Max verstappen
slap verstappen